Netflix says it doesn't let brands pay
for product placement so how do you
explain this you guys see that
that's the Malibu 24 MXZ its finest
wakes up number one in luxury quality
and performance this stores like this
they're designed for the Bobby Kemp's of
the world okay it's all organized in a
very logical structured way or this is
your finger looking good
all of those scenes are from Netflix
originals and they all feature branded
products in a way that feels a lot like
advertising so if Netflix says these
aren't paid promotions how are all these
brands winding up in your favorite
Netflix shows sweeter
better product placement is nothing new
and in the streaming era the practice
can take a lot of different forms
because first I have to drink my cherry
coke Zero some Netflix competitors like
Hulu have openly pursued a variety of
product placement deals Amazon has
ventured into shoppable product
placements for prime video and Disney
Plus is reportedly open to securing
product placement deals for its upcoming
original shows so what about the world's
biggest streaming service whenever
Netflix has commented on the brand
presence in this original series the
company has said that it generally
doesn't take cash from brands in
exchange for showing their products on
screen that's the old pay-to-play model
of product placement where brands simply
by screen times and in today's industry
it's just one of many ways for brands to
land their products in a show or movie
most of Netflix's statements though
refer to only this narrow definition of
paid product placement and don't really
address whether the company is working
with brands and other ways behind the
scenes of Netflix productions that may
be because Netflix wants to protect its
ad-free image I think it's because
Netflix really wants to avoid that label
of them selling out in any way this is
Dominic arcs Rooney and he's the founder
of concave a market research firm that
tracks brands placements in
entertainment product placement in most
people's mind is highly associated with
paid advertising being invasive selling
out despite Netflix's efforts to resist
the product placement label 1 2018 study
found that Netflix originals have more
product placement on average than non
Netflix originals and Netflix has a lot
to gain from showcasing brands in its
content whether or not those brands
actually pay for the opportunity
take the wildly popular Netflix original
movie 2018 to all the boys I've loved
before we can't have these contr and
subway cups out in the
pS that's a bit tight right there's no
mention of Subway sandwiches in the
novel this movies based on but Netflix's
rom-com made subway into a defining
feature of laura jeans best friend chris
who loves the chain sandwiches so much
that she texts in subway branded emojis
subway is known to push for a speaking
role for its products and TV shows
five-foot lots in Netflix clearly
granted it that into all the boys
Business Insider reported that a third
of Chris's screen time involves subway
in some way and the brand was weaved
into the very hot line of the movie at
one point Chris is craving subway so
badly that she ditches their usual lunch
in the cafeteria leaving Laura Jean to
eat with her crush Netflix got something
in return for this when the to all the
boys sequel rolled around in 2020 the
movie again featured aggressive subway
marketing in its prop design and
dialogue and subway in turn launched a
special campaign to promote the film
through its own marketing channels given
that millions of people eat subway every
day that's some valuable publicity for
Netflix this type of deal is called Co
promotional marketing and it basically
means that the two companies trade
promotions Netflix gave subway cultural
relevance into all the boys and subway
helps Netflix attract more subscribers
who want to watch this movie
clearly it's a smart business move for
Netflix to embed brands and its
programming even in cases where the
product placement seems to happen
organically like it did with Eggos in
stranger things a go said it was as
surprised as anyone else by his waffles
big role in the show's first season but
after seeing an unexpected boost in
sales the brand decided to partner with
Netflix and play up it's stranger things
moment
the two companies inked a deal for a
series of cross promotions including a
joint Superbowl ad spot that used a
throwback eggo commercial to tease the
second season of stranger things ago
meanwhile continued to appear throughout
seasons two and three of the show a
win-win for both companies plus after
featuring a brand in one of its shows
Netflix has a pretext to team up with
that company on all kinds of product
tie-ins
judging from the long line of product
launches around stranger things Netflix
is fully leaning into this kind of
merchandising now and the show's been a
perfect vehicle for this strategy thanks
to all the opportunities for 80s
nostalgia marketing Netflix has linked
up with brands to make stranger things
waffle boxes several models of bikes and
a whole slate of clothing and sneaker
lines characters even promote some of
the product lines in their costumes with
Dustin 11 and Jim hopper wearing pieces
from Netflix's clothing collabs in
several pivotal scenes from season 3
that's a lot of color for you chief it's
cutting-edge stuff all right iconic
characters on the show become
inextricably linked to certain products
just like we saw with Chris and Subway
into all the boys I've loved before in
that way Netflix seems to be following
the example of franchises like James
Bond a case study of great character
based product placement the Eggo waffles
become like a staple of 11 and no one
sees any of that as forced product place
and because it comes intertwined with
the character the perfect example of
this is James Bond Aston Martin has been
with James Bond since the beginning in
2019 Dominic's firm concave released a
report finding that over 100 brands
appeared in the third season of stranger
things in total giving those brands an
estimated 15 million dollars in ad value
within just three days after the
season's release as of June 2020 concave
estimated that number has gone up to 55
million and the biggest winner was
coca-cola concave found that the
company's drinks vending machines and
signage helped make it the most visible
brand in season
three its presence peaked in the finale
when Lucas interrupts all the action to
give a big long speech on the merits of
New Coke the flavor that launched they
had flopped back in 1985 slight
carpenters to thing the original is the
classic no question about it but the
remake sweeter bolder better this moment
felt a lot like a commercial I mean you
don't drink coca-cola classic
us kids like Coke it's like smooth it's
the latest and in a way it was right on
time coca-cola brought back new coke as
a special re-release with Netflix scenes
like this make the brand presence on
Netflix all but impossible to ignore
yet when Netflix saw Kon caves reported
on all the brand's in season three
Netflix his team reached out to Dominic
to push back on the use of one term they
hated the use of the term product
placement Netflix said that it didn't
accept payment for any of the placements
and stranger things they claimed the
product placements only you should only
call it that when money is exchanging
hands and that's a total
misunderstanding of product placement
it's true that code promotional deals
like those with coca-cola or eggo don't
require an exchange of money between
Netflix and the brand's it features but
as we saw in the Coke scene just because
a brand appearance wasn't paid for
doesn't mean it'll be any lighter on the
commercialism
you can argue over who's doing the
placing is that the company or is it the
producers at the end of the day we make
no distinction because the viewer
doesn't know doesn't really matter how
the redbones
scripted brand cameos like all the
subway references into all the boys
might make you wonder how did the brand
get there and how much of a say do they
get in the writing to answer this
question we went to branded
entertainment network or been a company
that specializes in setting up product
placement deals and that's gotten brands
into a bunch of Netflix
so we take what the brand is trying to
accomplish and we go and talk to content
creators in some cases we get to read
the script and if those content creators
are interested in that brand believe in
what the brand is trying to accomplish
within their piece of content we can
continue that conversation the producer
or the content creator really guides the
creative from there it's very easily not
going to work for a brand if it just
doesn't fit into the storyline
organically
so if producers not brands are running
the show why do we still get moments
like this 20 20 momu 24 MXC well its
finest week's header avoid quality
luxury and performance well the
producers themselves might be getting
money or free stuff from brands it's as
many of the biggest Netflix originals
aren't actually produced at Netflix the
streaming company can keep some careful
distance from all of this as it'll be
the production studio not Netflix itself
interfacing with brands and agencies
like Ben in fact a lot of the Netflix
shows that Ben has placed products in
have been produced outside Netflix like
fuller house where they landed Jose
Cuervo Jessica Jones where they got ten
cup whiskey or house of cards where they
got regular appearances for Dunkin
Donuts and General Motors in titles like
these that are produced out of house
Netflix will sometimes get a say in
whether brands make their way into the
script but if there are money or
contracts involved Netflix can pretty
much stay out of it while quietly
letting their producers take fees or
free products and services from brands
that happened with the 2018 movie like
father
another Netflix original produced out of
house Royal Caribbean gave the film crew
free use of one of its cruise liners in
other words a free filming location for
most of the scenes in the movie the
producers modified the script to include
details specific to the cruise liner and
the activities offered onboard even
adding a whole gameshow scene that
wasn't in the script before this kind of
assistance from brands in return for
product placement can help producers
save big
and stay under budget and it's good for
Netflix too for every platform
you want to empower your producers
allowing a producer to strike deals or
to do trade out with expensive
opportunities whether it be a location
or an auto or all of those things you're
empowering that producers you do that
extra shoot to do that really cool chase
scene or whatever it might be to move
that piece of content to the next on the
one hand these types of
behind-the-scenes arrangements can
result in pretty heavy-handed brand
messaging on screen but on the flip side
it can sometimes feel more intrusive
when shows avoid product placement
altogether the thing I find it actually
more unnerving than product placement is
when you see shows where they remove the
badges of cars so they've taped up the
back of computers or you know if you
have like blank cans of soda that's not
that's not realistic
Netflix's use of product placement is a
trade off for viewers the kind of deep
brand integration you see in Netflix
originals is less disruptive than
commercials and it might help Netflix
stay ad free while continuing to churn
out high-quality content but when brands
become stars in their own right it's
sometimes blurs the line between what's
an ad and what is it
[Music]
you
[Music]